[संगीत]
[प्रशंसा]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग दोस्तों एक बार आप
लोग बता दीजिए मेरी आवाज ए रही है नहीं ए
रही प्लीज एक बार बता दीजिए
नहीं ए रही
ओके थैंक यू कोई नहीं प्रिंस अगर आपको
आइडिया नहीं मिली तो आज हम दिखाएंगे अभी
कैसे मिलेंगे
तो आप सभी का स्वागत है अकादमी युटुब चैनल
पर
आज हमारी क्लास नंबर दे नंबर वेल है जो
कंटिन्यू चलेगी हमारी लैब जो लास्ट क्लास
में हमने टाइप की थी
लैब है और काफी रियलिस्टिक लैब है जो भी
आप लोगों ने अभी तक शिखा उसके बेसिस पर है
यहां पर सब कुछ अप्लाई कर सकते हो जो भी
आप लोगों ने सिखाया है तो
आपको मैं चलते हैं
तो एक कम करते हैं पहले ताश नंबर तू पे
हमने क्या किया जो इनफॉरमेशन फाइंड आउट की
थी ना जो यूजरनेम था टाइगर उसको हम फाइंड
आउट कर लेते हैं
इसको मैं क्या करता हूं ओपन करता हूं
क्लिक करता हूं और यहां पर
अकाउंट है हमारा कोई कम नहीं है वहां पर
इनफॉरमेशन करने के बाद परफॉर्म कर लिया
कुछ इनफॉरमेशन
अवेलेबल है अब क्या करें क्या करते हैं वन
बाय वन चलते हैं
हम चलते हैं इसके अंदर जो टास्क
नंबरिंग इनफॉरमेशन अबाउट डेम आफ्टर डी
अटैक
ऑन ट्विटर और टॉम
एडिशनल इनफॉरमेशन वे कैन लॉकेट तू गेट एन
आइडिया ऑफ वेयर दे आर हेडिंग तू नेक्स्ट
एग्जांपल
करने मेरे बड़े में तो उन्होंने क्या किया
उसने किया है कुछ इनफॉरमेशन के साथ
मैनिपुलेशन किया है और उसके बाद उसने क्या
कर दिया की यहां पर जो आपको देखने को
मिलेगा स्क्रीनशॉट देखने को मिलेगा तो
उसने क्या किया की एक टोंक किया है तंट की
मतलब कमेंट किया है की ट्विटर पे ही डोंट
थिंक की आई डोंट सी व्हाट यू आर डूइंग ये
मत सोचिए की मैं नहीं देख सकता आप क्या आप
लोग क्या कर रहे हो की यू वुड डोंट कैच मी
आप लोग मेरे को नहीं पकड़ सकते आई एम
ऑलरेडी हेडिंग बैक होम बाय मैं ऑलरेडी
अपने घर की तरफ जा रहा हूं तो इन्होंने
क्या किया हिंट यहां पर हमें हिंट दिया है
हमें कम करते हैं कोई नहीं हम वापस चलते
हैं इसके ऊपर तो
चलो चलो स्टार्ट स्टार्ट
ओके ओके ओके ओके
करंट ट्विटर हैंडल अटैक्स का करंट ट्विटर
हैंडल क्या है देखो करंट ट्विटर हैंडल की
बात करते थे अटैकर्स का करंट ट्विटर हैंडल
ये है हमारे पास यह इनफॉरमेशन है ऑलरेडी
चलो
बताना है जहां पर अटैक करना है वी-फी
पासवर्ड को स्टोर किया हुआ है
पासवर्ड को क्या किया हुआ है
मुझे जस्ट ए 1 मिनट मुझे कल ए रहा है
आई एम सॉरी पर था देखिए क्या है की अगर आप
इसलिए नहीं फाइंड आउट कर पे क्योंकि यह
इतना इसी टास्क नहीं था देखो यहां पर इसने
इन्फो इनफॉरमेशन आपको दी हुई है देखो
जब ट्वीट्स आपने पढ़ा होगा की यहां पर
ट्वीट्स में क्या दिया हुआ है की मैं एक
बार जूम कर देता हूं थोड़ा सा आप लोगों को
फॉरगॉटेन मी आप एक्सेस पॉइंट व्हेन आई गेट
न्यू फोन ओके
इसमें क्या दी हुई है की नोट ट्रू कंसर्न
अबाउट सम वन एल्स फाइंडिंग दम ऑन डी डार्क
वेब ओके
अन्य वन हूं वन डेम बिल हैव तू बी रियल
दीप सच तू फाइंड वेयर आई टेस्टेड डेम
देखिए अगर आप लोगों को कुछ अगर यहां पर
अजीब नोटिस किया होगा देखो ये पहले क्या
बोल रहा है की नोट थ्रू कंसर्न्ड अबाउट सम
वन एल्स फाइंडिंग डेम ऑन डी डार्क वेब
मतलब क्या है की यहां पर मिलेगा यह डार्क
वेब का कुछ जिगर कर रहा है
उसके बाद क्या है
बिल हैव तू डू ए रियल टिप्स अब देखना
पड़ेगा
सर्च करोगे
एक दीपेस्ट होता है उसका नाम क्या है दीप
पेस्ट अनियन डॉट अनियन वाला और उसका लिंक
कौन सा ये वाला लिंक है दीपेस्ट अनियन
लिंक और इसके अंदर आप क्या करते हैं एक
सर्च ऑप्शन होता है जहां पर आप क्या करते
हो की जो वो md5 है पुतिन करते हैं और
वहां से वो इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिलेगी
यहां पर कोई क्रिएशन लीकेज है तो ये जो
क्रैडिश्नल्स है आपको यहां जाके देखने को
मिले देखने के बाद देखने को मिलेंगे देखिए
ये वाली ये जो md5 है आपको देखने को मिल
रहा है इसको कॉपी करोगे तो वहां पर पेस्ट
करोगे तो तभी आप सर्च कर पाओगे बट
प्रॉब्लम इसे डेट की जो लिंक है जो ये दीप
बेस्ड अनियन वाला जो लिंक है ये रहा ये
अभी कम नहीं कर रहा है ये क्या है अभी कम
नहीं कर रहा है क्योंकि देखो मैं इस पे
क्लिक करता हूं तो ये क्या है की मैं आप
लोगों के लिए इसको क्योंकि ये लिंक काफी
टाइम लगेगा ढूंढने में क्योंकि दीप में
सर्च करोगे तो ये आसानी से मिल नहीं रहा
है तो जैसे मैं इस पर क्लिक करता हूं तो
देखिए ये ओपन नहीं हो रहा है लिंक ये लिंक
ओपन
जो सर्चिंग वाला ऑपरेशन है वो परफॉर्म
नहीं कर का रहे तो इसलिए मैं हम क्या करने
वाले हैं अभी क्योंकि देखो इस पे हम टाइम
वेस्ट नहीं करेंगे लेकिन हमें जिसको सर्च
करना था जो इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग करनी थी वो
हमें डायरेक्ट वेब पे जाके ही करनी थी तभी
इसके बड़े में हम वो चीज पता कर सकते हैं
जो ये क्या चीज लिखी हुई है यहां पर
एक्चुअल में जो ये md5 है जब इसको हम उसके
अंदर सर्च करेंगे पेस्ट भी अंदर वहां पर
आपको कुछ ऐसा ही देखने को मिलेगा देखो ये
ये कुछ ऐसा देखने को मिला दे दीपेस्ट v3
ये हुआ
ये लिखा हुआ है इसमें दीपेस्ट इसमें ये
लिखा हुआ दीप सीट पोस्ट पर स्पेशल सीट ये
इसने लिखा रेगुलर वी-फी और पासवर्ड यहां
पर कुछ इनफॉरमेशन लिखी हुई है देखो कुल्फी
कंप्यूटर लैब इसका एक्सरसाइज
और पासवर्ड देखिए
उसके बाद स्कूल वी-फी सोसाइटी पासवर्ड
जो लिंक हमारा ओपन नहीं हो रहा था वो
इनफॉरमेशन हमें यहां पर देखने को मिलती है
देखो अभी यहां पर क्या ये वाली चीज है वही
यहां पर क्या है इसके अंदर है ये जब आप
उसको क्या करते हैं 75 एमप्लीफायर है इसको
सर्च करते तो यही इनफॉरमेशन आपको देखने को
मिलती है अभी क्या ये वो यूआरएल है ये वो
ये वाला मैं कंट्रोल सी करता हूं इसको
क्योंकि इसको सिंपली आप सीधा पुटिंग कर
देना अभी कंट्रोल भी शायद यही होना चाहिए
अभी जहां से मैंने क्या किया इसकी रिंग से
उठाया क्योंकि इन्होंने ये हिंट में जाइए
तो इनमें इसलिए लिखा हुआ इन्होंने क्या
बोला देखो अभी एचटीटीपी ओके
तो एक्चुअल में इसके आंसर हमें मिलेगा ही
नहीं क्योंकि प्रॉब्लम यही है देखो डोंट
फॉरगेट ओके
ओके
यहां पर और हम
एचटीटीपी करते हैं इसको एचटीटीपी
पब्लिक में पीएनजी
आंसर
डीसी को फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश जहां से
हमें यूआरएल को पता करना है तो वो यहां से
हमें मिल नहीं का रहा है तो एक कम करना
अभी देखो हमारे पास क्या इनफॉरमेशन मिली
हमारे पास इनफॉरमेशन है ये रहा ओम वाई-फाई
और इसका पासवर्ड अभी एक और चीज है अभी
आपको क्या करना है इसने क्या बोला है की
व्हाट इसे डी यूआरएल पर डी लोकेशन वेयर डी
टाइगर श्रॉफ दे ओके 1 मिनट 1 मिनट 1 मिनट
क्या करना है व्हाट इसे डी यूआरएल पर डी
लोकेशन वेयर
वेयर थे अटैकर वी-फी पासवर्ड और पासवर्ड
तो देखते हैं एडरवाइज क्या है की नेक्स्ट
क्वेश्चन पर चलेंगे व्हाट इसे डी बस आईडी
पर डी अटैक ऑफ वाइफ होम वी-फी कैसे फाइंड
आउट करोगे नेक्स्ट क्वेश्चन जो है आपको जो
बोल रहा है की व्हाट इसे डी बी एस एस आई
दी ऑफ अटैक्स ऑन वी-फी अब इसकी भी
एक्सरसाइज भी कैसे फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं
देखो ये रहा आपके पास क्या है अभी से आईडी
है दी के 1f और जी ये इसका पासवर्ड है बट
क्या है की हमारे पास इसकी ओनली बस से
आईडी है बस आईडी नहीं है ये साइड बेसिकली
क्या है मैं एक एड्रेस होता है आपको देखने
को मिलेगा बेसिकली क्या होता है एक मैं एक
एड्रेस होता है फाइंड आउट करने के लिए
हमें क्या जाना पड़ेगा
नेट करके वेबसाइट होती है यहां पे आपको
क्या रजिस्टर करना पड़ेगा और रजिस्टर करने
के बाद आपको क्या करना है यहां पर लोग इन
करना है लॉगिन करने के बाद आप यहां पे
क्या कर सकते हो की अगर आपके पास बस
एक्सरसाइज ये तो ऐसे साइड यहां पर सर्च कर
सकते हो अगर आपके पास बस आईडी है बस आईडी
यहां पर सर्च कर सकते हो अभी मैं क्या
इसको थोड़ा सा और जूम कर देता हूं ताकि आप
लोग स्क्रीन पर दिखे जाएगा
डीके
वन
अप जी
तो होना चाहिए अभी
[संगीत]
हम क्या करते हैं
कैपिटल दी के
वन एफ दास
करने की कोशिश करते हैं नहीं कर का रहा
अभी देखो यहां पर हमें कोई इनफॉरमेशन मिली
है या नहीं मिली
[संगीत]
कमर्शियल पे ओनली ओके
इट्स नोट ओपनिंग
[संगीत]
वर्किंग
चलो
एडवांस
करते हैं हम
[संगीत]
है
पीकेजी है
चलो एक कम करते हैं क्योंकि ऑप्शन तो यहां
तक ए गया हो सकता है की कुछ चेंज हो या
कुछ प्रॉब्लम होगी बट वहां तो नहीं चाहिए
1 मिनट यह रहा
हूं
और हमें कम करते हैं
इसको कैसे डाउनलोड
[संगीत]
हमें चाहिए
हमारे पास
में भी कुछ नहीं ए रहा
है
देखो नीचे आया है
ड है उसके बाद ये है लट्टीट्यूड
लोंगिट्यूड ओके चैनल 11 है और ये इसको
हमें यहां पे कुछ रिजल्ट देखने को मिले
हैं अमेजन
बीएसएफआईडी देखने
[संगीत]
जिनके यहां पे शो करेगा इसमें
कहां पर है कहां पर है आईडी यह रहा यहां
पर है यहां पर देखने को मिल रहा है आपको
यह सोसाइटी यह है
एड्रेस देखो एड्रेस यहां पर देखने को मिल
रहा है आपको एक एड्रेस देखने को मिल रहा
है
आपको देखने को मिल रहा है हम इसको क्या कर
देंगे कॉपी कर अरे यार
एड्रेस में हमें देखने को मिल गया यहां पर
कुछ एड्रेस मिला है ओके कॉपी करते हैं और
इसको सर्च कर देते हैं अब हमें एड्रेस
मिला है
की कौन सा एड्रेस है
[संगीत]
गूगल ट्रांसलेटर
गूगल
अरे उठो बेस्ट
हीरो सा की सिटी
सबको समझ में
कंट्रोल भी करो
कंट्रोल भी जीपी 036 नंबर एड्रेस है
क्योंकि इसका यूआरएल फाइंड आउट करना थोड़ा
सा तब पार्ट है टू पार्ट इसलिए क्योंकि वो
वेबसाइट कम नहीं कारी जिसके थोड़ा
एक्जेक्टली तक पहुंच सकते हैं
तो यहां से क्या करते हैं हम एक बार गूगल
सर्च गूगल मैप पे चलते हैं और
गूगल मैप गूगल मैप पर चलते हैं और उसकी
जगह फाइंड आउट करने को करेंगे जो हमारा
एड्रेस है चलो गूगल मैप पे चलिए अब तो ये
हमारा एड्रेस है तो क्या करते हैं
सर्च करते हैं
आइडिया देखने को मिलेगा
हमको
जिला कोर्ट
जापानी
इनफॉरमेशन
[संगीत]
भी थे कोऑर्डिनेटर कहां पर हमारे पास है
लट्टीट्यूड और लोंगिट्यूड
लट्टीट्यूड और लोंगिट्यूड तो हम क्या करते
हैं वहां से भी कॉपी कर सकते
आप पेस्ट
लोकेशन शो
कर रहा
हम क्या करेंगे
इसको ओपन करता हूं तो मैं भी काफी बटर
तरीके से कम करें तो ये रहा और ये रहा और
पेस्ट
सैटेलाइट में कन्वर्ट कर लेंगे चलो यह इस
लोकेशन को शो कर रहा है बट ओके चलो हम
यहां तक है हमारे पास
क्वेश्चन हमारा क्या है चलो नेक्स्ट
क्वेश्चन पर चलते हैं हमारा ये क्या बोलना
है नेक्स्ट
होम माउंट अब ये बोलना है देखो बेडरूम
स तू पीस टुगेदर देवर रूट बैक होम आईएफ वे
फॉलो डेट ट्रायल ऑफ रेड क्रमश बिहाइंड वे
शुड बी एबल तू ट्रैक डियर मोमेंट्स फ्रॉम
वन लोकेशन
व्हाट एयरपोर्ट अटैक
नहीं कोशिश करें
[संगीत]
आप न्यू तब न्यू तब ओपन किया हमने इसको
ओके
इमेज पर चला हूं और अपलोड फाइल करता हूं
इमेज को ओपन भी करता हूं देखो यहां पर
जूम करूं इसको जूम इधर तो हो नहीं रही है
क्योंकि हमारे पास ये इमेज है इमेज को अगर
हम ओपन भी करते हैं हमारे फाइल में तो आई
थिंक की ज्यादा जूम नहीं कर पाएंगे
देखो इतना जूम कर का रहा हूं अगर आप देख
का रहे हो तो एक दो तू वे दो एक सड़क
दिखाई दे रहा है ये सड़क है ओके साइड में
एक घर है उसके बाद सामने कुछ एक बड़ा टावर
सा दिखाई दे रहा है या सामने टावर दिखाई
दे रहा है इधर साइड में कुछ लेख टाइप की
दिखाई दे रही है कुछ लेक टाइप का दिखाई दे
रहा है और ये कोई पांच भी दिखाई दे रहा है
कोई पाठ पे ये कोई पाठ वे और नो इशू हमें
कम करते हैं इसको
क्योंकि रिवर्सल से स्टार्ट कर चुकी है
चलो हम रिवर्स सर्च करें स्टार्ट किया था
ये रहा तो गूगल लेंस ने किया फाइंड आउट
किया है यहां पे विजिबल मैचेस आपको देखने
को मिल रहे हैं चलो हमें ये क्या
यूनिवर्सिटी ओके देखो इसको ओपन न्यू तब
करते हैं ये इनफॉरमेशन वाले कुछ हो साबित
हो शक्ति है और क्या करते हैं ये भी देखो
सिमिलर इमेज आपको देखने को मिलेंगे
[संगीत]
यह रहा कुछ है
यूनिवर्सिटी पार्क कैंपस तू अंडरगो वेरियस
समर कंस्ट्रक्शन प्रोजेक्ट ओके देखो ये इस
टाइप का दिखाई दे रहा है चलो यूनिवर्सिटी
पार्क आपस स्प्रिंग सितंबर यहां पर ये
क्या है
ये कहां पर है ये अब इसको
पर क्योंकि हमारे पास ही हो सकता है
[संगीत]
क्लियर क्लियर हो जो क्लियर हो जो आईटी
बिल टेक टाइम
[संगीत]
ओके और कुछ नहीं है आप हमें देखने को मिल
रहा है
[संगीत]
सर्च करें तो हम कर सकते हैं
ये क्या है
यूनिवर्सिटी पार्क कैंपस
कम करते हैं यह कॉपी करते हैं और इसको
सर्च करते हैं
कैंपस
यूनिवर्सिटी
[संगीत]
नथिंग अवेलेबल
कुछ स्पेशल शब्द भी हो सकता है इसको क्या
करता है
देखो देखो ये साड़ी काफी कुछ इमेज देखने
को मिल रही है आपको
यह रही यह रही यह रही यह रही
कुछ यहां पर तो एक कम करते हैं और क्या है
[संगीत]
यूनिवर्सिटी पार्क
जापान जापान इसमें देखते हैं इसमें क्या
मिलेगा
इसमें
क्लोज करते हैं और इसको क्लोज करते हैं
नेक्स्ट
जापान
प्रिंस कुछ मिला
यूजलेस
को
कंट्रोल
अब मैं अगर इसको बोलूं सर्च करने के लिए
चलो वह कुछ हमें देखना है
क्या
चीज है इसको हम ट्रांसलेट करते हैं गूगल
ट्रांसलेट करो
वाशिंगटन मोमेंटम ओके लोकेशन तो हमें
मिलेगी
चलो हमें थोड़ा सा आइडिया मिलेगा यह राव
सिंह तो मोबाइल खत्म होगा और यही पर क्या
है कुछ ना कुछ हमें देखने को मिलेगा
हमें
जूम करते हैं चलो
ओके ओके
[संगीत]
हेलो हम एक कम करते हैं इधर कहानी है
चलो चलो
एयरपोर्ट
[संगीत]
में क्या है
और अगर हम देखें तो उसके आसपास देखो क्या
अगर
हम देखें इसकी बात करते हैं
[संगीत]
आपको उस मिलेगा 360
की है चलो
आइडिया गैस कर सकते हैं हम क्या कर सकते
हैं
यहां पर अगर हम एयरपोर्ट
[संगीत]
यूनिवर्सिटी है जहां तक मुझे ग रही है
यूनिवर्सिटी को यूनिवर्सिटी
ओके ओके थोड़ा सा क्या काफी चैलेंजिंग चीज
हमारे लिए बस क्योंकि देखो
हम क्या करते हैं
हमारे पास क्या-क्या शब्द है हमको कुछ
करते हैं
दिल्ली दिल्ली
[संगीत]
चलो चलो चलो
रोनाल्डो वाशिंगटन नेशनल एयरपोर्ट
रोनाल्डो
हो सकता है एयरपोर्ट अगर और थोड़ा सा और
कंफर्म करेंगे हम
हम
एयरपोर्ट हो सकता है और ऊपर से यह पार्क
है और
वह हमें बिल्डिंग अगर देखने को मिल जाएगा
यह रही इमेज हमारे सामने
यह है वह बिल्कुल सामने है एक बिल्डिंग है
यहां तो वाटर है इधर यह है उसको है
और जो हमारा गूगल लेंस का आया था
जो रिजल्ट में आया था हमारा
ट्विटर सर्च
चलो चलो
नो नो नो नो नो
एयरपोर्ट
है
उधर
यूनिवर्सिटी है
जापानी
यह रिवर्टर बॉडी इसकी साइड में
अगर हम पर देखेंगे इस साइड से ही पड़ेगा
चलो हम इधर कहानी अगर हम चलते हैं इसके
सामने देखते हैं इधर
इधर
[संगीत]
बेसिकली देखो हमारा एयरपोर्ट जहां तक हमें
बिल्कुल सर क्योंकि देखो जगह वही है यही
वो सामने हमने क्या है वाशिंगटन डीसी हमने
फाइंड आउट कर लिया और जो चीज बात कर रहे
हैं
इसके बिल्कुल सामने मतलब वो कहानी इसी
एरिया में इमेज है क्योंकि देखो वाटर
बॉडीज जो हमें देखने को मिल रही है वो ये
है तो इसी एरिया में इमेज और यहां पर जो
एयरपोर्ट है यही है अब इस एयरपोर्ट का नाम
देखिए हम क्या है इस एयरपोर्ट को क्या
बोला जाता है कुछ है क्या इसको शॉर्ट
फॉर्म हो गया यू एयरपोर्ट की तो एयरपोर्ट
का नाम है तो ये हो सकता है ये है
पेस्ट करते हैं एयरपोर्ट का नाम
करते हैं
यह करेक्ट यह हमारा आंसर
की आंसर है ओके ओके वहां पर
कितना टाइम लगेगा
थोड़ा सा और मेरे को बता देते यार टाइम
वेस्ट किया मैंने व्हाट एयरपोर्ट डिड डी
अटैकर हैव देवर लास्ट लेवल अब लास्ट लेवल
की बात करते हैं ले अब ये क्या बोल रहा है
चलो तो लास्ट एयर की बात करता हूं कौन सा
हो सकता है ये रहा हम बैक करते हैं ट्वीट
पे
इसने लिखा है
तो अब इसको भी हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा इमेज
को डाउनलोड करना पड़ेगा
हेलो अभी देखते हैं क्या फाइंड आउट कर पर
ओके यह रिव्यू
[संगीत]
मिल रहा है
उसके बाद है यह रहा मतलब एक यह वही चीज
दोनों ही से ही है तो यह वह इमेज है मतलब
यह कौन सा है एंट्रेंस तू डी जल सकुरा और
फर्स्ट क्लास मिल गया हमें किसका नाम मिल
गया इसमें क्या बोला है
तो हमें क्या मिल गया जापान एयरलाइंस हैं
जापान एयरलाइंस
है वो कहां पर है ये फर्स्ट लॉन्च क्लास
सेंटर व्यू ये रहा इसका नो इशू इसको मैं
अभी फाइंड आउट करना है कहां पर है
तो इसका कौन सा एयरपोर्ट
में लिखा जाता है
लेंस का कुछ नाम है
नेक्स्ट है
चलो ये भी हम फाइंड आउट कर देंगे
इसको हम इमेज सर्च यहां से कर नहीं सकते
और ओपन इमेज इन युटुब ओपन कर सकते हैं
इमेज ओपन होगी इसको
इमेज कर सकते हो हमारे पास एक कम कर सकते
हैं अभी हमारे पास एक लोकेशन है वी-फी
लोकेशन है हम इसको एक कम करते हैं नॉर्मल
चलते हैं चलो इसको हम वापस वापस जूम आउट
करते ए जाते हैं जूम आउट करते हैं क्या ये
मैं वही बन रहा है क्या
ये रहा
देखो यह वहां का है
देखो अगर आप देखोगे एग्जैक्ट ऐसी ही वो
पिक्चर है ऐसी वह पिक्चर आपको देखने को
मिल रही है यहां पर देखो ऐसे ही है ये रहा
और आगे मैं कर सकते हैं
ये रहा बिल्कुल इसके
बन रहा है
मतलब ये है वो लेख इसको हम जूम करते हैं
अरे नहीं नहीं
चलो
अरे भैया
लिखकर क्लिक कर देंगे यह रही लेक इसका में
नाम चाहिए बिल्कुल कॉपी करते हैं
हमने क्या किया था चलो और हमारे पास यह
रहा हमारे पास देखो
सर्च करने की परिभाषा
1 मिनट 060
कर सकता है क्यों एनिमल
लेकिन अगर यहां पर अगर इससे आइडिया लगाएं
हीरो साथी कहां पर है हीरो सखी वैसे क्या
है जापान में ही है क्योंकि आपकी राशि
आपने सुना होगा तो मतलब क्या हीरो था की
जापान में ही है तो हम आइडिया लगा सकते
हैं इसके बेसिस पर हम एक लोकेशन मिलेगी और
वो जहां तक आईडी आया है की क्योंकि इस
सिटी की मिलेगी ढाका वो होम का वी-फी है
होम वी-फी आपको देखने को मिलेगा तो हमें
क्या करना है उसका आंसर भी देना पड़ेगा
एनिमल फाइंड आउट कोई पता कर का रहा है
क्या
बताओ
इसमें क्या पूछा है हमारे पास जो आंसर
चाहिए उसको यह है
तो इसको ही कंसीडर कर सकते हैं वैसे अगर
मैं बोलूं बिल्कुल क्योंकि हमारे पास एक
लोकेशन यह है जो हम अगर इसको हम वापस से
चलते हैं
ए गया
अरे नहीं नहीं
अगर हम जाएंगे तो यह है इनफॉरमेशन में
बोलना है
की एक ही जगह के परिवार की लोकेशन शो
करेंगे तो ये क्या है वही एरिया मिलेगा
जहां पर उसका घर हो सकता है तो हीरो राइट
आंसर बिल्कुल करेक्ट वैसे हम एकदम टाइप कर
लेते हैं
अभी एक ही आंसर बच्चा है हमारे पास इसको
फाइंड आउट करना बहुत ही अभी क्योंकि वो
वेबसाइट चल नहीं रही है ये वाला लोकेशन
[संगीत]
तो आज का चश्मा वहीं पर एड करते हैं
क्योंकि अभी सिविल को हमें तभी लिख सकते
हैं
अभी क्या है
बिल्कुल राइट
साइड मिली थी जहां पर सो आईडी मिली थी
उसके बीच में हमने जो बस आईडी फाइंड आउट
की थी अकॉर्डिंग तू
सिंगल सर्च
हम बात करें
वाईफाई इनफॉरमेशन देखने को मिलती है
क्योंकि खास कर ये सब अपडेट हो ड्राइविंग
का ऑप्शन उसे करते हैं
और यह तो उसे टू है बिल्कुल इसी लेबर काफी
अगर आप इतना लास्ट वीडियो लेकर अभी तक आप
लोग क्या करवा रहे हो मेरे को क्या फॉलो
कर रहे हो ना तो आप उसको नहीं मैं बता रहा
हूं आधे घंटे में सॉल्व कर डॉग
वेरी वेल
[संगीत]
यह लाइव आपके सामने
डाउनलोड करोगे
हम कैसे पता करें क्या तो एग्जिट का भी
इसमें शायद इनफॉरमेशन करने में हेल्प मिल
जाए वैसे एग्जिट की इनफॉरमेशन कहते हैं
आपको दिखा दिया मैंने मटर डाटा के थ्रू बट
इसमें मिल शक्ति है
आप लोगों के लिए जो भी क्लास लाइव क्लास
में आते हैं वेरी थैंक यू और जो लोग इसको
बाद में जो रिकॉर्डिंग को देखते हैं उनके
लिए भी बहुत ज्यादा धन्यवाद जो रिकॉर्डिंग
को देखते हैं और अगर वो टास्क परफॉर्म
करते हैं तो बहुत ही अच्छी बात है लेकिन
हमें पता नहीं चल रहा है क्योंकि वो हमें
कोई भी रिपोर्ट नहीं भेजते लेकिन हां एक
चीज है एक चीज
देता हूं की जो लोग अभी क्या करते हैं तास
परफॉर्म करते हैं और जैसे की प्रिंस है या
एक दो लोग जो गूगल ड्राइव
हमें क्या करते हैं की तास सबमिट करते हैं
क्या करते हैं
जो अच्छे अच्छे रिपोर्ट बनाते हैं उनके
लिए क्या है की मैं उसको ऑब्जर्व करूंगा
और जो बेस्ट रिपोर्ट लिखना ना जो काफी
डिटेल में भेज स्क्रीनशॉट और काफी क्लियर
और मतलब की हर लेग्स को सॉल्व करता है या
जो भी तास परफॉर्म करता है काफी क्लियर और
काफी डिटेल रिपोर्ट लिखना है तो उसको मैं
क्या है
मैं उसको भी उसको क्या है की मैं क्या
करूंगा की पर्सनली उसको मैसेज करूंगा और
उसको हम क्या करेंगे उसके जो जो बेस्ट
टास्क उसमें लिखा हूं जैसे की हमने जो भी
लैब सॉल्व की है एक तोलाब ये हो जाएगी जो
आप लोग आगे ए टास्क परफॉर्म की है अगर आप
लोग नहीं कर पाओगे एक दिन बता देना लास्ट
में हम इसको सॉल्व कर लेंगे और एक लैब
पूरा करके जो लैब अभी हमने इसमें सॉल्व
करें और एक ये भी तो ये रही सर्च लाइट हम
ऑलरेडी सॉल्व कर चुके हैं ये इमेज और सेंड
के ऊपर हो जितनी भी लेफ्ट हमने परफॉर्म
किया हैं या जो भी आपने एक डिटेल नोट्स
बनाया था प्लीज बनाया और एक कम करना बोल
रहा है मेरे से करके भेजते रहिए मैं
देखूंगा पर्सनली मैं देखा भी हूं और मुझे
अच्छा लगता है की अब जिसमें बोल रहे हैं
काफी अच्छे लिखा है बट क्या है की एटलिस्ट
अच्छी-अच्छी रिपोर्ट बनाई है और पर्सनली
मैं बता रहा हूं की उसकी रिपोर्ट मैं हम
अपने पेज पर रखूंगा
यह शिखा इतनी डिटेल रिटर्न इसमें लिखी हुई
रिपोर्ट और ताकि लोग उसे रिपोर्ट को चाहे
आपने कोई भी सॉल्यूशन किया हो चाहे किसी
भी लैब का सॉल्यूशन किया हो चाहे आपने
किसी इमेज को सेंड किया है जितने भी टास्क
हमने किया हैं जो टास्क मैंने आप लोगों को
दिया है उनका जो डीटेल्स समरी रिपोर्ट
आपने बनाई है 0
क्लियर समझ में ए जाए इसका मतलब क्या है
उसको हम क्या ताकि लोग समझे और इन्फ्यूजन
उसका रेफरेंस में उसे पर कमेंट आए और वो
कमेंट आपको सुनके काफी अच्छा लगा है ओके
दान है
प्रिंस या ललित लक्षण है या लर्निंग अबाउट
यह हमारा कोई बांदा होगा मुझे लगता है और
एक और है
जो बोल रहा हूं एग्री विद मी
लोगों में खुद से कुछ भी कपड़े करके लगा
तो आप लोगों को सामने सब कुछ परफॉर्म करता
हूं ओके
इंस्टाग्राम
[संगीत]
हैकिंग करो या ना करो लेकिन आपको रियल
लाइफ में चीजों को सर्च करने में काफी
हेल्प करेगा तो कभी आप एक क्रिएटिव मन
रहेगा आपका क्रिएटिव चीजों को फाइंड आउट
आसानी से आप कर पाओगे विद डी हेल्प ऑफ ओपन
सोशल इंटेलिजेंस कभी भी अगर
आप लोग साथ कोई भी घटना करता है तो आप
उसको क्या है एक लेवल तक
ओके